ce mardi 28 septembre le tribunal
judiciaire de paris a condamné ta boîte
à une amende de 1500 euros c'était le
sujet le plus commenté aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux et forcément c'est
dans touche pas à mon poste il était
poursuivi pour une injure publique en
raison de l'origine de la policière
linda québec qui l'avait traitée d'
arabes de service en juin 2020 sur
twitter regardez petit récap de la fère
et aboaf sera bien sûr ici avec nous car
il a fait l'actualité donc il est sur le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste
regardez
[Musique]
la sentence est tombée 1500 euros
damende pour le journaliste aboaf la
justice vient de le condamner pour les
propos qu'il avait eu à l'encontre de la
syndicaliste policier à linda kebab je
sais que enfin la personne qui m'a
insulté et journalistes un tweet plus
précisément publiés puis supprimés en
juin 2020 qui se voulait volontairement
provocant ads arabes de service linda
qui bavent a tenu à réagir sur son
compte twitter en se félicitant de cette
condamnation les mensonges déshonorant
de ta aboaf à mon encontre ne lui
permettent plus de cachet qu'il est bien
raciste la justice vient de le condamner
pour injures racistes elle a précisé
qu'elle reverserait l'intégralité des
dommages à des oeuvres sociales pour des
familles de policiers alors arabes de
service comprenez vous que le
journaliste la buav soit condamné à 1500
euros pour cette injure contre une
policière table c'est avec nous merci
d'être avec nous tu as on verra bien
donc un peu plus de 1500 euros d'amendé
on va parler dans un instant il s'est
passé quoi en juin 2020 en fait il faut
replacer un peu de france et cela dans
le contexte en fait ça fait suite aux
manifestations qui ont eu lieu lors de
la mort de georges floyd aux états unis
et les manifestations en soutien à la
famille awa traoré donc devant le
tribunal de paris donc une grande
manifestation antiraciste pour dénoncer
le racisme dans la police le racisme
structurel et les violences policières
sur les habitants des quartiers
populaires et donc tout ça voilà c'est
un contexte bien précis de critique de
l'institution policière et du racisme
systémique et donc
il ya une émission de france info ou
linda kebab donc syndicats disent
policière qui est syndicaliste le
syndicat unité sgp police qui on le
rappelle un des responsables de syndicat
avait dit à la télévision que dire
[ __ ] un noir c'était à peu près
convenable je me souviens pas d'avoir vu
linda kebab se soulever contre ça eh
bien elle avait pris la parole pour dire
que la mort d'adama traoré et la mort de
georges tron n'était pas comparable que
la police aux états unis que la police
en france n'était pas du tout la même
chose on sait que ils sont tous les deux
morts
sous le poids de policiers par asphyxie
donc c'est quelque chose de totalement
comparables et linda kebab voilà elle
passe son temps sur les plateaux de
télévision a nié les violences de la
police a nié leur alors juste devant
police et le problème cyril c'est quoi
c'est que en fait en faisant faisant ça
en fait elle convoque elle-même son
origine pour justifier ses discours chez
bourdin elle disait voilà la police
n'est pas raciste pour preuve je suis
moi linda kebap donc arabe et tout ce
qui va avec porte parole de bon nombre
de mes collègues et c'est ça le problème
précisément arabes de service dans ce
contexte là c'est une critique de son
discours politique fatale à l'origine
qui peut croire que je suis raciste
contre les arabes c'est que c'est
complètement ridicule alors vous avez
twitté donc ads arabes de service suit
celui de france info et vous allez me
intérieur j'assume totalement mon
dernier huit jeux les supprimer car j'ai
oublié que dire le mot arabe peut avoir
un banc de tout à l'heure en cas de
signalement massif c'est ça donc voilà
qu'on faire ma dernière suspension de
compte alors j'ai condamné à payer une
amende de 1500 euros vous devrez aussi
payer 2000 euros de dommages et intérêts
à linac 3500 euros en tout non non il ya
beaucoup plus en fait c'est un oui
l'euro dommages-intérêts puis les
avocats puissent ils craignent donc ça
va t on ainsi à 1500 euros dans l'es6
le tribunal a considéré que l'expression
arabe de service constituent un propos
outrageants et méprisants envers linda
kebab et quand le tenant aboaf s'est
volontairement fondée sur son origine à
laquelle il l'a réduite pour la signer à
une place peu valorisante voir
dégradantes pour une syndicaliste ce qui
a par ailleurs effet de décridibiliser
ses déclarations c'est ce qu'a dit juste
rapidement il faut quand même rappeler
que
que voilà il ya une audience qui s'est
tenue une audience qui a duré 10 heures
10 heures d'audience où on a fait
témoigner des sociologues du racisme des
historiens de -10 me des militants et
cinq policiers arabes et noirs mais
quand parce que le narratif de l'undac
et bob c'est quoi c'est de dire au fond
est par ailleurs ça peut se comprendre
et je ne renie pas d'ailleurs ce tweet
si je les supprimer c'est que évidemment
que c'est un tweet qui est provocant
évidemment qu'elle a pu sentir outragé
par par ce tweet je lirai supprimer
quelques secondes après les renier du
sort c'est que elle se dit blessé de ça
mais c'est elle qui en a fait la
promotion j'étais à une table avec des
journalistes quand elle envoyait un
grand communiqué c'est de
l'instrumentalisation politique c'est
bien son droit je comprends pas pourquoi
la judiciariser ça mais bon ce que ce
que je veux vous dire c'est qu'on a fait
une audience de 10 heures et le narratif
de linda québec c'était quoi c'était de
dire que en fait à abu hafs il ne
supporte pas qu'on puisse être policier
et arabes mais c'est à dire donc aimer
la france ait porté l'uniforme des
rythmiques c'est complètement fou
puisque on a fait citer cinq policiers
arabes et noirs notamment des gens de
son site dans son propre syndicat qui
ont dénoncé leurs attaquants qui sont
policiers dont qui a priori aiment leur
métier et qui ont dénoncé le racisme
dans la police et quand ils ont dénoncé
leur assise devant la police qu'est ce
qui s'est passé mais se retrouver
placardisé ils sont retrouvés avec des
enquêtes comme amar ben mohamed vous
savez ce bengali et chef du tribunal de
paris qui était au syndicat de linda
khaimah est dès lors qu'il a dénoncé ce
racisme il a perdu son mandat syndical à
la sgp elin et là il a dit à la barre
que linak et mam ne lui a plus décroché
au téléphone elle a incarné salariat à
boire dix heures d'audience donc j'ai
été condamné à 6500 euros à peu près ça
vous dit ouais mais juste pour revenir
sur ce que vous disais sur les menaces
qu'ils essaient que en fait ce qu'elle
reproche c'est là l'assignation
identitaire c'est mieux finalement
puisque l arabe et policières elle ne
peut être que le pantin d'une
institution raciste et que je lui ronnie
tout libre arbitre non elle peut faire
le choix de dénoncer le racisme dans la
police elle a fait un choix sauf que
votre tweet et est réducteur puisque
votre tweet il dit il ne dis pas que
tout ce que vous venez de nous raconter
qui au demeurant pourquoi pas la
critique de l'institution policière on
peut l'entendre le fait qu'il y ait des
dérapages alors systémique ou passé
chacun il décide si c'est systémique ou
pas mais ça on peut l'entendre sauf que
dans la réduction ads arabes de service
on n'entend pas tout ça on entend
simplement une essentialisation d'une
personne qui dit en gros par pas par
essence par on vous réduit à ce que vous
êtes c'est à dire une arabe donc de
service et donc tout ce discours que
vous tenez là il ne tient il n'est pas
dans dans le tweet vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire par là c'est à dire qu on
entend juste arabes de service et donc
essentialisation de la personne mais
c'est ça non dossier passionnant mais
ces deux services et ce qu'elle aime en
effet de serre vous savez très bien
c'est pas une wii maram de service au
deuxième jeu
dire qu'elle était instrumentalisée ça
je l'aurais aujourd'hui désormais si
c'est ce qu'il a voulu dire de série
mais
moi je trouve que cette décision allait
consternant parce qu'elle sous-entend de
dire d'un arabe qu'il est arabe dire
d'un blanc qu'il est blanc dire d'un
noir qu'il est noir c'est raciste c'est
pas ça le racisme le raciste c'est
adopter un comportement discriminatoire
envers quelqu'un en raison de sa couleur
de peau de son origine et c'est le cas
par exemple
tous les jours
tous les gens qui ont un problème avec
les terres noires arabes qui ose pas
dire les choses qu'ils oui mais c'est
une personne un peu c'est eux les
racistes il faut dire en arabe c'est un
arabe un blanc-seing blanc au noir c'est
noir il ya rien de raciste là dedans et
par ailleurs quand même rappeler qu'il
ya des coups de butoir depuis des années
la part de l'extrême droite pour
retourner la définition même des rares
métiers non mais faut retourner
chaffardon jeu pour retourner même la
définition du racisme et l'utiliser
contre interactif vous connaissez la
formule les anti racistes sont les vrais
racistes qu'est-ce qui sait ce que c'est
ce qu'a dit linda d'hayange voix la voix
c'est ce que vous avez dû vous les anti
racistes sur les vrais racistes c'est ce
qu'avait dit vous avez un bon deal à
thumeries et géraldine là je te trouve
très naïve guillaume et moi j'avais
d'abord je suis complètement libre à
kebab et je me réjouis de cette
condamnation je pense qu'en fait que les
têtes de gondole de l'antiracisme
aujourd'hui sont très dangereux vous
essentialiser tout vous avez dit la
police française c'est comme la police
américaine c'est faux il peut y avoir on
a dit oui il avait dit ça m'avait dit
que nous verrions pour la labellisation
que le genre et deux avis ni sur le même
plan georges floyd et l élan réformiste
on a dit que vous avez toujours gallois
d'avoine traoré sont mortes dans les
mêmes conditions c'est zizou avait dit
que leur police et oui mais vous avez
dit que la police française et est
restée structurellement et oui mais non
mais c'est l'histoire d'un policier
cette année sauf que me semble sans
faille à taipei dit enfin en elle une
partie des arabes on ne peut pas ils se
gagnent ou dix ans n aura rien en
français en voyage de 8 jours monsieur
en france et une police des noirs non
arabes de service pour moi ça veut dire
qu'à des bons arabes et des noirs et
arabes de la même manière elle a un ton
par des [ __ ] de salon c'est dans le
bailleur oui les [ __ ] de salon fait
pâle comme sale indigné alors que vous
savez trés maison il est indigène east
les [ __ ] des maisons et de salons
mondiaux comme abdoulaye comptes etc et
comme par hasard une noire épouse une
formule de malcolm x d'ailleurs malcom x
qui ont été condamnés en france en 2021
pour les gros font mine alors si partez
pas vous ne supportez pas pour moi vous
êtes aussi dangereux que zemmour de
loterie et bien sûr oui appuyé le croire
même et donc je suis très content et biz
et gilles verdez gilbert binette je vous
avais pour d'accord avec la même
approche morale du racisme mais de
racines c'est un système de domination
politique mais pas dit qu'il ya une
histoire vous vous dites moi que tu
prends racine on y fait bon monsieur
parce que je veux s'il prend racine dans
la colonisation dans l'esclavagé
nous répondons qu'il ya lui conséquence
on est pour la vie des gens et jeunes
filles au plaisir à dean sale rat si
j'ai envie d'avoir gym à une posture
morale et puis ça arrange bien je vous
dire à vous dire franchement oui ça
arrange bien tout un tas de gens de se
dire que finalement le racing n'est pas
que le monde n'est pas que l'eau chaude
et blanc c'est une réalité le racisme
aujourd'hui c'est une histoire blanche
le racisme en france il ya aussi s'aider
soi blanche madame g les pc
gilles michel gilles verdez d'accord
avec ta boite mail a clairement c'est un
jugement politique on veut le faire
taire et je trouve ça dégueulasse arabes
de service pour moi ça ne méritait qu'un
non-lieu qu'une absence de poursuites
d'abord c'est un jeu de mots ads ses
adjoints de sécurité et reprend les
trois lettres arabes de service ça mais
en plus inséparables qui est important
vous vous trompez ces deux services et
le rôle social de la syndicaliste
policière qu'il dénonce donc pour moi il
faisait de la politique de la
provocation politique ça a été on
commande pages dûment justice mais moi
je le dis vraiment frontalement ce
jugement c'est une honte c'est un
déshonneur pour la france ça va faire
appel j'espère que l'on appelle vous
gagnerez il avait donc des temps pour
expliquer toute l'histoire et la
chronologie vous vous raccrocher aux
branches vous ramez et c'est pas vous de
décider mais la façon dont elle doit
l'interpréter le ressentir non mais oh
elle a ressenti comme une insulte vous
mettais plein de trucs d'ailleurs c'est
par de gentils comme
je le dis et je vais les dieux devant le
tribunal j'ai dit je reconnais que c'est
une expression qui a fait outre agente
qu'elle puisse sentir blessé que c'est
c'est dégradant ok ça peut même être
considéré comme une un jour je ne lis
pas mais pas une injure à caractère
raciste je n'ai pas visé parce qu'elle
était arabe c'est ridicule je vais pas
fâché contre moi même ça n'a vraiment
pas de sens et je vous le dis d'autant
plus qu' elle a vécu du racisme elle a
raconté aussi à la barre moi ça
m'attriste mais je trouve dommage des
conclusions qu'elle tire de tout cela et
voudrait qu'elle dise quoi que avril à
que la bougie choix j'ai assisté mais
moi j'ai moi j'ai pas à dire ce qu'elle
a à dire vous savez le racisme
systémique c'est pas le racisme
systématique ça ne veut pas dire que
tous les policiers sont racistes mais ça
veut dire que dès lors qu'on est
policier par exemple et qu'on dénonce le
racisme il ya tout un tas de mécanismes
qui vont venir se mettre en place pour
vous faire taire les noms vous mettre
sur le côté c'est exactement ce qui se
passe vous inviterez peut-être mais vous
avez déjà par ailleurs choix eu des
policiers ici qui m'ont raconté comment
est ce qu ils ont été mis au placard
quand ils ont dénoncé le racisme dans la
police et vous verrez que c'est le 6
tout un système qui se met en place pour
les faire taire et ses salars systémique
une réponse moi moi j'ai pas la même
culture que vous et que j'entends la
tous les trucs les phrases des machins
le racisme ça oui je comprends pas tout
d'abord d'abord j'aime bien ce que vous
faites vous sur twitter parce que vous
êtes au coeur de l'action il y en a de
ja vous et clément l'anneau que j'aime
bien parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya des
alors les parties ou droite gauche je
m'en fous vous êtes toujours au coeur
des trucs et sur twitter vous réalisez
toujours en premier ça c'est une chose
la deuxième chose pourquoi moi je dis ok
pour la condamnation puisque c'est une
porte ouverte à tous arabes de service
après on peut dire negro de maisons
après on peut dire juif après on peut
dire etc etc il faut expliquer toi t'as
l'intelligence de nous expliquer là que
oui c'était à ds est un jeu de mots
c'est est ce si c'est cela non moi je le
prends arabes de service et hippolyte
pour moi ces arabes de service et je le
prends comme une insulte tiens les
l'arabe de service va ramasser les
poubelles tiens t'es noir de service va
ramasser les poubelles je le prends
comme ça aram de services faut qu'on
arrête de voir ça il ya des gens qui
sont moins intelligents que toi qui vont
prendre arabes de service comme une
insulte donc moi je veux pas voir son
réseau twitter que toi tu n'es rien tu
t'es pas de poursuites et que demain on
puisse dire aussi negro de maison ou à
nous mêmes et à hilario licorne a diarra
ou encore une fois arabe de service
n'est pas sale arabe et arabe de service
pourquoi je le dis c'est parce qu'elle
est il ya toute l'extrême droite qui
chantent ses louanges ici même sur le
plateau de thé pmp gens mais siam est
cité son nom il a réuni avant d'ailleurs
damien rieu qui avait cité aussi son nom
elle est mais adoubée par les
je vous disais pas ces gars là ont
utilisé ce mot dont vous cette
expression dont deux avec l'egypte et
l'algérie après parce que parce que vous
savez cette locution n'était pas anodine
non dont vous les avez d'autres genres y
est tu dis ça mais vous auriez pu dire
procès linda qui bat kebab je pense que
vous êtes instrumentalisé vous êtes
naïve et ses mémoires qu'il est naïve
ailleurs je lui dit persuadé mardi je
pense qu'elle a un choix qui est celui
de servir une institution pour peut-être
des intérêts personnels moi je rappelle
juste une chose parce qu'elle s'en cache
beaucoup elle a été militant de la
france insoumise en 2007 elle a fait la
campagne de jean-luc mélenchon elle a
même voulu être candidate aux
législatives et du jour là mais moi j'ai
des camarades à elles qui ont milité à
quête d'un 12e arrondissement vous si
vous étiez rêver non mais moi je le
cache pas
ok je le rappelle mais moi je m'en cache
pas et donc elle disait oui suppression
de la bac les policiers n'en a et c est
du jour au lendemain dès qu'il a eu son
mandat syndical la sgp mais louise
attaque c'est boris abraham en sabre ou
pas si moi je trouve ça aussi une part
de 2 enfin elle sert aussi ses intérêts
personnels après libre elle mais c'est
le champ politique c'est le débat
politique va avoir le droit de la
critiquer aussi delphine maintenant
qu'on voit ce qu elle explique je
voulais vous demander ça vous sert à
quoi en fait ce combat-là de d'attiser
une genre de haine envers les policiers
est ce que vous voulez qu'on enlève
toute légitimité à la police parce qu'à
ce moment là qu'est ce qui va se passer
les faits qui sont isolées quand même
les faits racistes de racisme dans la
police sont isolés sont punis sont très
très médiatisé mais après il faut
arrêter de dire que toute la police
parce que sinon qu'est ce qui va se
passer avait pas entendu au plus vite
j'ai dit racisme systémique n'est pas
raciste mais cinématiques ce ne sont pas
tous les policiers mais quand un de mes
racines quand on à du racisme et des
faits de violence l'institution protège
l'institution couvre les syndicats
couvre rien que rien que ya quelques
jours j'ai sorti une enquête sur noisy
le grand un gène qui s'est fait tabasser
dans des angles morts des caméras de
surveillance eh ben les syndicats sgp
police donc le syndikat linda kebab
disait ah mais oui mais non mais en fait
c'est un il cherche à chaque fois des
stups ces systèmes a aimé va être
regardé revient derrière ici aussi au
plaisir et bene merci de services
comprenez vous que le journaliste à
boire sont condamnés oui à 68% non à à
31% ta bon voilà après voilà vous savez
tout cas y'a pas chaud à l'organiser